hey you guys welcome back to my flickers
of fear show and it's still march so
we're talking about monsters it's
monster march that's the theme for the
movie reviews this month
and this is a movie uh that i feel like
everybody had seen but me and so
i thought it was probably time to get
around to seeing it even though it's
technically
not really a horror movie it's more like
fantasy
romance but with some sci-fi and horror
elements um but you know i kind of like
genre crossers like that and as i said
it's you know it was a movie by
guillermo del toro who i'm a big fan of
and i don't know why it took me so
[ __ ] long to see this movie because i
had really been jazzed about seeing it
and for whatever reason i just never got
around to it this is the shape of water
from 2017.
now as i said i kind of feel like
everybody's probably seen this by now um
it won best picture uh in the 2018
oscars was nominated for uh i believe
guillermo del toro won best director as
well i think it won four oscars and was
nominated for [ __ ] tons of other awards
golden globes and all this other stuff
so it got like tons and tons of awards
and tons of accolades uh seems to be
pretty critically almost universally uh
beloved
although i think there is kind of like
maybe a small contingent of people that
didn't really dig it but
i have to say that
i don't know what it why it took me so
long to watch this because this was
i mean it was just like a beautiful
movie like all around and i'm not just
talking about a beautiful looking movie
which it certainly was that
but i mean just like the whole
uh kind of theme of it the whole
the whole idea behind it was just like a
really beautiful idea i think one of the
things that i really like the most about
guillermo del toro as a filmmaker
is that i really like that he seems
just so like not cynical
he's uh you know and i i don't
necessarily want to say he's a romantic
because that's kind of sounds
dismissive but i mean it in the sense
that he really does not seem to have a
cynical bone in his body his movies are
very
heartfelt and they're very genuine and
he seems like not afraid of
talking about
love and emotion like in old-fashioned
sort of fairy tale sort of context
where
you know maybe some people might say it
was too corny or something like that and
he has actually said uh things to that
effect when uh he's been interviewing
he's like you know people are just so
cynical nowadays and it's like they
don't really want to talk about you know
you talk about these kind of things like
in this movie these you love stories and
stuff and everybody is just you know
[ __ ] on it because there's like oh
it's corny or whatever so i admire his
kind of balls in coming out and being
like no it's not corny you know and just
like letting it all hang out there and
being very genuine about it and i can't
really think of another filmmaker at
least one uh you know that's as widely
known as he is that's operating in that
same kind of thing i mean his love of
cinema
really like oozes from every frame of
every single movie of his that i've seen
so the fact that he made this movie
which is essentially um you know it's
not an original story it's you know an
update or kind of an inversion i guess
of beauty and the beast but really it's
kind of an uh an update of
a creature from the black lagoon but
sort of a take off of that
so uh if you haven't seen it this will
probably this will have some spoilers um
because i feel like even though this
movie was you know came out four years
ago something like that uh but i do kind
of feel like it was such a big cultural
thing and it won best picture so i feel
like even people that haven't seen it
probably know
like what happens in it or kind of knows
what happens at the end so i'm not
really all that worried about spoiling
it because i feel like this was a pretty
widely seen film at the time and you
know even nowadays so the story behind
this if you don't know uh it's actually
set in 1962 in baltimore i had actually
didn't know i mean pretty much the only
thing i knew going into this movie was
kind of like a weird i don't want to say
weird because again that sounds you know
derogatory and i don't mean it in that
sense but
you know obviously the big thing
everybody took away from this is like oh
a human woman falls in love with a fish
man essentially uh you know and yes they
do have sex with each other and maybe
some people were weirded out by that but
honestly
watching the movie
one it
it doesn't uh what you know when you say
like a human woman falling in love with
a fish man and having sex with a fish
man like it sounds a lot weirder than it
actually comes across in the movie and
the movie isn't just about that it has
like a bunch of other stuff going on
which as i said i didn't realize um you
know just
from a cursory like read about it that
it was a period piece and that was a set
during the cold war so that kind of
brought like a different sort of uh you
know sensibility to it i guess and it is
done very much like a fairy tale but it
does have a lot of realistic stuff in it
and i think that he did that
i think he wanted to set it during this
particular time period and i'll get into
probably why he did that in in a bit
but
in a lot of ways like a lot of
filmmakers do this a lot of writers do
this uh where you kind of set something
back in the past because you're trying
to say something about
uh you know the present day but people
be more receptive to it i guess like if
you know it's if it's couched in other
terms you know where it's like
that was a long time ago and maybe
people watching the movie now weren't
alive back then so we're just kind of
like doing that
so i kind of feel like that's how we did
that but i think it was like a really
good uh time to set it in so it said in
1962 in baltimore and we're following a
woman named eliza
and she is a mute woman uh she was an
orphan
they uh they say at some point in the
film
she was found like by the side of a
river or something like that like as a
baby and it looked like she had been
abused there are these scars on the side
of her neck which is presumably what
made it her unable to talk
so she works as a cleaner
at this sort of kind of top secret like
government research facility type thing
uh so she works there her best friend
there is uh played by octavia spencer
and she kind of like you know octavia
spencer's character kind of translates
for her and just kind of like sticks up
for her says they've known each other
for a very long time
so
that's she has that friend uh you know
and then also
her neighbor she lives kind of in this
apartment by herself
over an old uh movie theater which seems
like it's not doing all that well
uh and her next door neighbor is this
older man
named giles who
uh was an advertising executive but uh
has been having trouble finding work it
for a lot of reasons but one of the main
reasons being that he is like an
illustrator in the sense that he paints
things by hand and a lot of the
advertising in 1962 was going more
toward like photographic representation
so he's not really getting a lot of work
anymore he's also a closeted gay man
and uh as i said he's middle-aged he's
getting a little bit older and so it's
kind of hard for him to like sort of fit
in in 1962 he feels like a little bit of
an outcast and indeed that seems to be
like the main
theme of the film everybody in this
really is some kind of outcast uh you
know you have the main character eliza
who is an orphan and she's mute you also
have her friend who's played by octavia
spencer who's a black woman in 1962.
baltimore kind of like a working-class
black woman you know you have giles who
is you know a closeted gay man and also
who
seems to be and he even says this at
some point uh he seems to be like
really really into old stuff like old
musicals and old style of art and things
like that but then in some ways um he's
kind of like really likes old things but
he's really kind of like ahead of his
time as well so he's kind of like a man
out of time uh so again like misfits so
that's why
when this secret cup government uh
agency that uh that eliza works at when
they bring in this
sea creature essentially the which they
just call the asset
uh they bring it in there and keep it in
a tank
they apparently found it uh you know in
the amazon
and they said the locals worshipped it
as a god
and they basically just captured it uh
and they want to figure out if there's
some way that they can
use it to
get uh you know a leg up on the soviets
because as i said this is the cold war
so michael shannon uh plays colonel
strickland who is the guy that caught
the the asset uh you know or amphibian
man if you want to call him that uh he's
played by doug jones by the way who doug
jones plays pretty much every anytime
you see a guillermo del toro movie with
a creature in it
it's probably doug jones in there uh and
i really have to i love love love the
amphibian man design of this obviously
very influenced by
a creature from the black lagoon which
as i said there was numerous uh
interviews with guillermo del toro at
the time this movie came out
and he said the idea for this movie
came from seeing creature from the black
lagoon when he was six years old
and thinking that uh the gill man and
the female lead were going to end up
together like it was going to be a love
story and then being because he was a
little kid and he was kind of like
bummed out when that didn't happen
so um
you know what i mean because you know
the the gill man was kind of like a cool
you know he was a humanoid figure and
you know he just kind of got shot by the
people and that was you know he was kind
of wanting to invert
the the universal monster thing
even though some of the universal
monster films and some of the other
monster films of like the 1930s and
stuff you know king kong obviously or
you know the original frankenstein did
have some kind of like sympathy for the
monster
uh a lot of the movies and this kind of
went through the 50s and stuff as well i
mean anything that looked like a monster
was a monster and just like pretty much
had to be destroyed and he kind of
wanted to invert that a little bit
so michael shannon
uh his character colonel strickland who
is just
the [ __ ] worst i mean he's like a
villain but
i don't know i kind of feel like one of
the main criticisms people have with
this they thought that his character was
too one-dimensional or he's too like
overtly villainous i didn't really find
that um and one kind of interesting
thing that guillermo del toro said about
his character and he said that him and
michael shannon had talked about this
was that he's like at least in the first
part of the movie had this movie come
out in the 1950s for example colonel
strickland would have been seen kind of
like is a good guy
even though um you know he's a bit
sadistic obviously but
if this had been like a traditional
monster movie where the amphibian man
was actually a monster
then colonel strickland would have been
the hero he said you know this kind of
square-jawed you know white dude that
was coming in and like figuring
everything out and he's the one that's
gonna have to like destroy the uh
monster so he kind of wanted to like
subvert that
50s trope a little bit as well
but the interesting thing about michael
shannon's character
is that even though he's obviously the
villain and he's very hateable and uh
you know i feel like michael shannon
poor michael i love michael shannon so
much by the way but i feel like he
always plays parts like this i guess
just because of how he looks but he
always kind of plays
he doesn't always play psychos but he's
really really good at it which like i
said i guess that's kind of why but he's
really good in this i like him a lot but
you know even though as happy as you are
when you see him get his just desserts
at the end you know because he was such
a such an [ __ ] like throughout the
whole entire movie it was just kind of
like throwing his dick around everywhere
you know metaphorically
it was uh
the movie does actually take pains to
show a little bit of
not so much a human side but kind of
shows why he is the way he is
um and showing that
he's not really a happy person either
it's like he has what on the surface
particularly in you know the 50s and
early 1960s in america would have seemed
like the ideal
uh you know life he's got like
the classic nuclear family he's got a
beautiful wife and two kids and he has
like a really nice house and he buys a
new cadillac and
all and he has a good job and stuff like
that but you can tell that he's not
fulfilled by that and as the movie goes
on uh you know as he gets more and more
villainous you learn that he's a little
bit
he's a little bit of a victim too
because he's not
uh he's never kind of like lived up to
what he thought he should be able to
live up to and he's got other guys over
him
that will basically well if you [ __ ] up
then you're out on your ass you know
what i mean so he doesn't really have
a lot of power either and it really does
seem like he's having a hard time
dealing with that eventuality
particularly in his interactions with
like the five-star general that's like
you know that outranks him and you know
him him thinking that all he has to do
he just has to like do all this stuff
and prove himself and then he'll be like
top dog but that's not how that works
out so
the fact that it's not working out just
like makes him angry and angrier but he
does like at the very end does seem to
realize
uh you know would have like a little bit
of a come to jesus moment
where he recognizes
the humanity and actually in some ways
the sort of like superiority i don't
know if i want to use that word but he
recognizes um you know the amphibian man
actually having uh you know powers and
stuff like that and actually being kind
of god-like uh you know and so he does
recognize that at the end like before he
gets killed spoiler alert so essentially
what happens in the movie uh eliza
because she's like a cleaner and she's
mute and so she sort of like fades into
the background
so she's kind of like allowed to go a
lot of places in this facility because
no one really notices her no one really
notices any of the cleaners really
so she ends up cleaning
uh this one uh place where the amphibian
man is being kept because
during uh colonel strickland michael
shannon's one of his little sessions
where he just keeps like shocking the
thing just
seemingly to kind of keep it in line and
like show that he's the boss or whatever
and uh amphibian man gets mad and bites
off two of his fingers and there's blood
everywhere so she has to go in there and
kind of like clean up the lab
now she immediately develops an affinity
with this amphibian man
and interestingly even though everybody
else
essentially sees this creature as a
monster she um
because he can't talk but because he's
like humanoid he seems to
respond to her and she seems to respond
to him as
like i said they have like an affinity
with one another like she recognizes his
otherness and as like mirroring her own
otherness so over time she starts like
bringing him eggs and she like plays
music for him and so they develop this
like uh you know deep kind of
relationship with one another she
teaches him sign language so he can
communicate with her and other things
like that so
then she finds out or like overhears
that uh at some point
they're like okay we don't really think
that this is gonna be any uh help to us
in our you know fight with the russians
or whatever so we're gonna vivisect him
to see what we can get out of this and
then we'll just like throw him away so
she finds out about that she flips out
and she said we have to get him the [ __ ]
out of here so she tries to
there's a there's a great scene where
she tries to um
convince giles to like help her and he
doesn't want to at first because he's
like look we're we're nobodies we're
we're nothing we're like at the bottom
of the [ __ ] barrel what can we do we
can't help anybody we can't help
ourselves it's like why why even bother
but she actually does uh bring him
around to like helping her
she's like look how can you call
yourself a human if you are not willing
to help out it's like he's intelligent
you know he's
he has just as much right as the rest of
us and it's like something terrible is
gonna happen too if you don't do
something so uh he does actually end up
helping her and they also get help from
this scientist that works there who
is actually uh you don't know this until
a little bit later but he's actually
like a soviet like spy
but he's also a scientist and he seems
like he's really not happy with like
either [ __ ] side because he does not
want to kill the uh the amphibian man
because he's like look there's so much
we could learn from this this is a new
species it seems intelligent it seems to
have emotions and it seems to like
respond to you know people and uh you
know the the the top brass and [ __ ] like
they're like we don't want to hear that
and like [ __ ]
we don't want to hear that crap so uh
you know they're like we're just gonna
kill him just forget about it
so
he uh actually does end up helping them
as well so they actually do she actually
does manage to uh bust amphibian man out
and she keeps him in her bathtub
and she's going to release him like back
out into the sea like when the uh rains
make the canal like high enough that it
goes back out to the ocean so she's like
made her plan to do that at some point
uh as mentioned and like i said probably
the biggest thing that everybody talked
about in this movie even though yes it's
in the movie but it's not
really the point of the movie uh but
yeah she does uh actually end up having
sex with the fish man and there is a
very funny scene where she explains to
her friend um
how it was possible like i guess like
how a cloaca works so there was that uh
whole thing too but honestly i like i
know that it's very like giggly and
teehee and everything like that but i do
kind of like
that this is like i said essentially
like a beauty and the beast story
but it's not like a disney fine like
uh you know oh lovey-dovey everything
like that like they're in love but
there's also like a sexual component so
it's much more like realistic in that
sense and i like too that one of the
first things they show before she even
meets the fish man
is
her having like a normal sexual drive
like they show her like masturbating in
her bathtub and things like that so
they're and they're just showing that as
like just a normal part of life it's not
you know seen as anything like cd or
anything like that she's just like a
normal woman with like normal sexual
needs and i thought that that was kind
of cool that they sort of addressed it
like that so that's what i mean when i
say yes you can like make jokes about
having sex with a fish man but
it sounds weird when you say it but when
you see it in the movie or at least when
i saw it in the movie it didn't i don't
know it didn't strike me as particularly
bizarre or particularly gross or
particularly anything like that because
i mean and you have to say too that like
the makeup that they did
on doug jones um you know yes he looks
like the creature from the black lagoon
essentially i really like the way they
did the eyes it's almost all like
practical effects by the way
but you know he still looks humanoid so
you know it's not like crazy to think
that somebody would be into that i mean
i guess it's like less weird nowadays
because you know people like furries and
all that kind of stuff so
so it's not really that that strange try
to really like think of it it's that
strange but uh but yeah so that was one
thing that i kind of liked about it so
as i mentioned um you know there's a
whole thing toward the end with
uh the soviet scientists
helping them out and then michael
shannon finding out because at first
like he thinks that it was this big like
[ __ ] crack spy team that came in
there and stole the asset and at first
he signed he court he kind of like
refuses to believe
that it was just like a cleaning lady
you know what i mean and a couple of her
friends uh who helped he who busted this
uh this fish man out but uh you know so
there's a thing like a pursuit toward
the end where he's
you know his ass is on the line too so
he's like i have to find this the fish
man within so he has to let go track it
down he just kind of gets crazier and
crazier as it goes on and more and more
murderous and villainous uh because he's
again uh you know has
has realized that he doesn't have as
much power of the situation as he
thought he did um you know so there's
that whole thing too and uh again toward
the end it kind of goes
in a direction sort of like
end of creatures in back black lagoon
because the fish man does get shot
but it turns out that
the uh you know the the natives and the
amazon who were worshiping this creature
as a god we're actually not too far off
because he actually does have sort of
like healing powers
and uh so like i said michael shannon
before he actually gets killed by the
creature and rightfully so i have to say
um does actually acknowledge uh you know
he says you are a god and then he gets
killed
now let's kind of talk about and i know
that someone was probably gonna ask me
about this
i had remembered okay so when i started
watching this movie
and there's the scene
in uh giles's apartment and he's got a
bunch of cats and i was just like uh oh
i think i remember somebody saying
something about the fish man eating a
cat and i was just kind of like do i
want to keep watching this is really
gonna upset me because you guys know how
i'm about cats and then i was like yeah
i'm pretty sure i do remember that oh
[ __ ] i was like oh man why why why you
gonna do that and honestly it was in
this movie it was he does eat one of the
cats and um it was like actually like
worse than it was because normally like
you see in a movie it's like just rare
and you know it's the thing and then
sometimes i'll show like the aftermath
this one he actually like ate the cat's
head off and i was just like oh my god
i was so so upset and honestly i was
thinking about this earlier i was like
could i have done without that honestly
because
it did make the monster
well you know he's not a monster he did
make the fish man
like less sympathetic
but then in a way i was kind of like but
maybe that was kind of the point though
because he's still
even though he ha he's capable of
empathy and he's capable of emotion he's
capable of understanding he's still a
wild animal and he didn't know any
better
like you know if he lived in the amazon
presumably he ate other little animals
all the time and so he didn't understand
that that was someone's pet you know
what i mean so i'm not really sure like
if i cause you know any time they do
like mean stuff to cats and especially
if it's kind of like this i'm not going
to say it's played for laughs in this
because it's not really but it's not
made in it's not like a humongous deal
they do kind of like giles does kind of
make a not a joke but he does just make
kind of an offhand comment about it's
like you know yeah i'll forgive him for
like eating one of my cats but it's like
you know if that was me i'd have been
like really really upset about it um he
had two other ones but still i don't
know i didn't love seeing that because
it did look really realistic and it was
like really gory and like upsetting
but i can see why it's in there i don't
think it was just in there as like a
cheap oh my god he ate a cat i think it
was just to show
because one of the themes of it and you
know eliza goes into this at some point
she's like the reason that she feels an
affinity with the fish man is because he
looks at me
and doesn't see me as like lesser or as
something like
defective or whatever the word was that
she is because she can't talk uh whereas
like other humans would look at her like
there was something wrong with her but
to him
uh it didn't make any difference so he
just like saw her the way she was and
the thing that i liked about this too
was that she liked him the way he was
because like you because remember in
beauty and the beast you know she was
beautiful uh you know she was kind of
like a nerd or a weirdo or whatever uh
but he looked like a beast but he
changed into like a handsome man like
toward the end so they could actually
like get married or whatever and in this
one there is no transformation like
she's like she actually kind of
transforms because she goes into the
water and then it turns out those scars
on her neck um you know become gills so
is so it's kind of hinted that either
uh she was uh kind of like amphibious
the whole time which is maybe why she
was found you know by the side of the
water like as a baby or he was able to
make like take the scars which a lot of
people
uh you know gave her [ __ ] about not
really but i mean it was something that
was like an imperfection and made it
into like a life-giving so now she can
live under the water with him so it's
like a fairy tale type of situation so
she transformed but he didn't and that
was kind of the cool thing is that
neither one of them really changed
because she was a good person the way
she was and she accepted him the way he
was and he accepted her the way she was
and that was kind of like
like i said that was sort of like the
message of the movie i guess was that
you know they they kind of came at each
other with no judgment uh you know
either way and i thought that was kind
of like a cool
uh subversion you know what it's i just
thought of this but i was watching
another video
about the about this movie about the
shape of water
and uh the woman made a really good
point i wish i could remember what it
was but the woman made a really good
point when she said you know everybody
was like all flipped out about her
having sex with the fish man but she's
like now think about though if the movie
if the main character was a man and the
monster was a mermaid because they've
made a lot of movies like that like look
at [ __ ] splash from 1984. she was a
mermaid you know that's she's not a
human and nobody really was grossed out
by that you know what i mean so why
would you be grossed out if it was the
other way around and i'm like yeah
that's actually a good point i haven't
thought of that because he's essentially
he's a merman i mean you know yeah his
top half doesn't look like i mean he
looks like creature in the black lagoon
obviously he looks but he still looks
like a person he's still got like hands
and feet and legs and he's two-legged
and everything like that so he's still
like humanoid he just looks like kind of
fishy
so it's it's that kind of thing it's not
it's not that big a deal but uh but yeah
so anyway um i really loved this movie
um
i just thought it was a gorgeous like
gorgeously shot i loved all the colors
like especially like all the green and
just all the watery stuff and then he
used like red he's i was watching an
interview with him and he said he used
red
if at particular times red always
represented either love like you know
when she jumps down with him at the
bottom or he like takes her down the
water at the bottom and she has like a
red coat on or
um it's represented movies or cinema
because this movie does actually have a
lot of homages to other films
um you know there's a lot of uh and old
tv shows as well so there's like a lot
of like old musicals there's a lot of
you know there's one scene where she
imagines herself and the fish man like
in an old like black and white musical
he was actually gonna shoot it in black
and white at first um and then he i
think he was kind of thinking oh well
maybe people would be like it would put
people at one remove when he wanted
people to you know really engage with it
as more slightly more realistic so he
decided not to but there is a sequence
in it that's in black and white that's
supposed to like that's supposed to be
like an old uh you know movie musical
you know like fred astaire or whatever
so there is a scene in there like that
but there are a lot of scenes like
people are watching you know old
musicals on tv like shirley temple and
things like that and
it just has as i said tons and tons of
movie references you don't
necessarily have to know what they all
are but i think if you do know what they
are it really kind of like
enriches the experience you know what i
mean and like he even said he's like he
didn't want to be like postmodern it's
like oh you don't have to know
what the references are what movie that
is you know that's playing within the
movie to
to get anything it's just that it's in
there and if you know what it is it just
kind of adds a little bit
extra like adds a little bit more
richness to the characters and
everything like that
um i also want to say too interesting i
didn't actually hear about this until
uh i was researching this movie i hadn't
heard about this at all but i guess uh
when this movie came out i guess um
guillermo del toro
got sued for plagiarism because there
was one guy who uh had written a play i
believe it was and uh the play was about
a cleaning lady who falls in love which
he doesn't really fall in love with but
develops like an affinity with like a
dolphin and then like helps the dolphin
escape and um
like kind of pointed out how similar it
was it was like a big 12-page thing it's
like look at all the similarities but i
think ultimately they determined that
uh it wasn't
like similar enough and honestly he's
like i never even heard of that play um
so i don't really and honestly it's not
like it was a hugely
famous one not that i know of i hadn't
really heard of it either uh but i think
that actually ended up not really going
anywhere so there was that but he did
get i don't know it's and it's weird
because as i said it's not a completely
original story it's like a beauty and
the beast type story or it's like
creature from the black lagoon but where
the gill man and the female protagonist
like end up together instead of getting
killed um instead of him being a monster
it's basically just like a more
sympathetic reading of that
but you know and he didn't really make
any secret about that he doesn't make
any secret about
all of the uh influences like all of the
movies all of the you know stuff that he
wanted to homage
when he was making this movie so
you know it's
again it's kind of like uh you know most
of his stuff
is very fairy tale based
and this one is no different i like too
and he also he did this in devil's
backbone and he did this in pants
labyrinth and things like that where he
really juxtaposes
this fantastical
uh kind of world with like a real life
horror this one was a little more on the
fantastical side didn't have as much but
there was like some pretty gross [ __ ] in
it too because like i said you know
michael shannon gets his fingers bitten
off and they sew him back on but it
doesn't quite take so as the movie goes
on like his fingers like start rotting
essentially like they start going black
and he like pulls him off at the end and
there's one shot toward the end where he
shoots the
the russian scientist
uh or he gets the russian scientists get
shot in the face like it goes like
through the cheek and michael shannon
like basically like drags him
by his face and it's like that part and
i was like oh god it was like that's
[ __ ] nasty and it was just so that's
what i mean it has
it's just like an interesting
juxtaposition of like this gorgeous
fairytale like magical world with that
kind of where it's you know every now
and then there's like a really jarring
um like horror like a gory type or
something like a really uncomfortable
like violet kind of thing but honestly
i
it's really hard to pull that off but i
feel like he always does it because
as i said guillermo del toro um he just
seems like
a just a lovely human being
and
he just seems so compassionate and so
empathetic and he just seems so genuine
and that really comes through in every
movie that he makes even
when stuff in the movie that's happening
is like horrific or you know or whatever
just this humanity of his like shines
through and so i think that's why i mean
that's why he's one of my favorite
filmmakers even when i even when he
makes movies that i didn't think were
like fantastic you know there's always
like something worth watching he's
always worth watching and i always like
listening to him talk about his movies
because his enthusiasm for them his love
for cinema is just so
infectious and i think that really
really comes out in all of his movies
and especially in this one i think this
one was
probably it seemed like one of his most
personal movies
and um really kind of like uh
one of his most beautiful ones beautiful
looking and just like beautiful in its
uh in its theme i guess of these kind of
like misfits or people that are always
like been thought of as other
and
how they sort of like find one another
you know and find their place in the
world and it's just like a really really
nice like i said he's always been one of
those people that felt like an outsider
himself so he always kind of
resonated with um you know
people or you know monsters and movies
like people that were like grotesque or
you know so he had a lot of sympathy for
them and i think a lot of that comes out
in most of his movies and especially in
this one as well uh so yeah the shape of
water at the moment as of this recording
it is on hulu which is where i watched
it i'm sure you can find it other places
as well let me know if you've seen it or
you know or whatever and if you did like
what you thought about it and that will
do it for this flickers of fear
continuing with monster march and i will
see you guys on the next one
bye